[Music]
hey you guys tomes of terror time once
again now if you guys watched i guess it
was on the last sidetrack show i think
at the very beginning of it um i said a
little bit of a crisis
like with the book that i was going to
review this week which i don't really
want to review now so basically the long
and short of it
is that the book that i was supposed to
review this week was actually one that i
mentioned way back on my tbr back in
january and it was one that i just
picked up kind of blindly from a used
bookstore and it turned out uh that it
was monster by frank peretti who um i
wasn't really totally aware at the time
is a writer of christian fiction which
like i said
it wouldn't be a deal breaker uh but i
did start reading the book which is
about bigfoot essentially
and uh
got about halfway and i was like it was
that's okay and you know it wasn't
really that you know egregiously like
over the top religious or anything like
that but then it got to like the
midpoint and there was this kind of big
long
uh screed about uh creationism and then
at that point i was just like man should
i waste my time finishing it because it
still had like two or three hundred
pages to go and it's like every time i
kind of tried to pick it up to finish it
i just ended up getting depressed again
so i was just kind of like you know what
i you know i was thinking about
finishing it and then doing a
review of it just
to like kind of make fun of it i guess
but then i was like why why would i
waste my time when there are like so
many other good books that i have on my
list that i've been wanting to read i
had to abort the mission
about but then i remembered that in my
kindle unlimited uh i actually had a
little novella which i had been wanting
to read i forgot that i had checked it
out like a few months ago uh because i
saw it recommended
on a couple of horror booktuber channels
i think adam cesar and uh jordaline
reads and stuff and they had uh you know
they had recommended it and i said ooh
that sounds a lot better and it's pretty
short it's only about 100 pages so i
figured well i can you know read this
really quick like in an afternoon and
then i can knock a review out and not
have to finish uh the creationist
bigfoot book which was depressing me so
much so i decided that i was gonna go in
there and do that one instead and i was
so happy i did because man this book was
like so much better than the one that i
was going to review this week which
probably like i said i'm not even gonna
finish now because
yeah but this book is actually called
larry by adam millard millard
however sorry adam i'm sure i'm
pronouncing it wrong uh i actually don't
have the print version of this
and it's very strange because if you
look on amazon there are print versions
of this book available like i said it's
a novella as you know technically uh
there are print versions of it and i
think the cheapest one is like 800
something dollars i'm not really sure
why but if you have a kindle unlimited
subscription you can read it for free
which is what i did
so i don't have a physical book to show
you but i will put the cover right here
which is actually like a really really
cool cover
so adam millard is a british writer uh
you know looks like punk rock dude has
big mohawk and whatnot which we we like
that and uh he's actually written a [ __ ]
ton of books this was the first time
that i had heard of him he writes a lot
of kind of apocalyptic bizarro uh
fiction a lot of erotic horror things
like that this one is kind of like i
kept seeing this one come up like i said
on a lot of other people's
recommendations and i was like this one
sounds like a lot of fun and indeed this
one is a lot of fun this might not be
like a super long review because the
story is you know not that long it's
only about 100 pages and it's not super
super complex but i will say
if you have kindle unlimited and you
have like a couple hours to kill and
you're really really into horror comedy
and you're really into like disgusting
over the top like slasher type stuff
slasher parodies then this will be right
up your alley because this book is
hilarious so basically what the premise
is
that there's a
serial killer much like a slasher type
killer like a you know jason voorhees
type killer uh called larry pigface
travers uh they call him pig face
obviously because he wears a pig mask
and you know kills people with an axe
and whatnot
so in this universe i guess okay so the
first part of it they do kind of like a
flashback i think the first part of it
is set in 1978 which like i said it was
it's the same year that halloween came
out the movie so it's kind of like when
a lot of the slasher tropes were
uh solidified i guess and this does kind
of go into a lot of
self-aware type of
you know like as it's essentially like a
slasher parody but it's also like a
slasher on its own right it's not scary
but it's real real gory real disgusting
and it's just like really funny
so like i said if that sounds like
something that you would like it is
pretty gross so know that going in uh
you know the descriptions of things but
you know if that sounds like something
you would like then you'd probably
really dig it so what happens is he goes
on this uh killing spree i guess he had
been on a killing spree like the
previous few years but at the beginning
he goes on a killing spree in 1978 he
kills you know however many camp
counselors those like 30 something
people at this place called diamond
creek uh you know your regular like kind
of summer camp
type uh situation
and uh he is actually down to the last
girl who is the final girl and she
actually gets away
by
essentially saying you know hey i'm the
final girl you're not allowed to kill me
you know so it's just and he's just kind
of like oh yeah i suppose so i guess how
that's how that goes so
he thinks that she's just gonna like you
know let him go and on about his
business or whatever but she actually
ends up trapping him in a bathroom and
setting the cabin on fire and for many
years like everyone thinks that pig face
the pig face killer is dead however this
whole entire time poor old larry pigface
travers has been living in this really
yucky like cabin
with his very very old mother and his
pet pig named wilbur
and he's kind of like been thinking so
like he's 65 years old now because this
book was actually came out in 2014 which
is also when the most uh the bulk of the
action is set and so he's 65 years old
now uh he's not in the best health
anymore he has trouble breathing like
all his joints are creaky and stuff like
that like most old people
but all this time he's been thinking man
he really really wants to get back into
like the heyday when he was just going
around like slaughtering a bunch of
teenagers and you know he's really
missing it
so uh so his mom is trying to like talk
him out of it maybe you should do like
sudoku or like take up knitting or
something like that you're too old for
this [ __ ]
but
he uh ends up succumbing to the uh the
draw of his pig mask uh who he actually
kind of talks to uh it either talks to
him or he imagines that it talks to him
um so he ends up succumbing to that and
decides he's gonna go back to diamond
creek and kill a bunch of campers and so
it turns out too that even though that
camp uh you know where he did all the
killing back in the past was abandoned a
long time ago because of all the mass
murders you know which is probably what
would happen and a much nicer newer camp
has been built like about a mile or two
away
um there are a group of really stupid
and really like stereotypical slasher
character archetypes that are coming up
there because they want to like you know
do all this stuff away from everybody
else they all have names that refer to
other horror movies
you know like you know one of them's
last name is voorhees one of his last
name is meyers so like that so he's like
it's very very self-referential and it's
just really like all the horror movie
like all the slasher movie tropes are
kind of you know expounded kind of
played upon and jokes are made out of
all of them and honestly it's like not
every single joke lands really but it's
like most of this was just like laugh
out loud funny i mean seriously you have
to have a particular kind of sense of
humor because it's pretty sick
um you know what i mean like especially
there's not a lot of sex there's not a
lot of sexual stuff in it there is to an
extent like you know just like there is
in slasher movies but most of the humor
is based around like just being gore
like gross out kind of humor
um you know people's faces getting
chopped off um there's one very like
particularly hilarious sequence with one
couple who wants to like out freak this
other couple like sexually and they're
like doing all this crazy [ __ ] and that
like part was really funny too but it's
like pretty much everything and this is
funny it's just kind of like there's you
know there's a jock there's a ditzy
blonde there's token black characters
there's you know what i mean there's a
there's a geek uh who's there and it's
so they have this kind of like whole you
know all of these stereotypical
characters that larry is joyously coming
back and he's coming back to his own
even though there's scenes where you
know that some of the victims are like
talking to him and he's just like hey
can you just like give me a minute so i
can get my breath back and stuff because
he's 65 years years old and he's still
trying to be like jason voorhees and
stuff which is like i said that is a
genius
premise in itself um i was looking at
some of the other goodreads reviews most
of which are very very positive and like
i said i would give this one a very
positive review too it's very breezy
it's really fun and it's just like i
said if you have like a really sick like
gore-focused like sense of humor and you
really like slasher movies then
this should be right up your alley and
it's like a quick read i think it took
me maybe like an hour and a half to read
it um and it's just like a fun it's just
so fun and so funny uh but yeah so
you know it's just the premise of it is
great and like i said one of the
goodreads reviews uh that i read of it
said you know it's you know it's kind of
like a one joke story but it's a damn
good joke and i will give it that and
like i said it doesn't wear out it's
welcome it's very short like it's maybe
like maybe like 100 pages um you know
you can read it in a couple of hours and
it's just like a good time it's just
like watching a stupid funny
super super over the top gory disgusting
slasher movie like in the best possible
way like i said it's not scary or
anything like that it's just meant to be
funny and over the top and disgusting
and it totally totally succeeds on all
of those uh on all of those aspects uh
the weird thing about it and some a
couple people brought this up too and i
was a little bit
it was a little bit jarring at first i
think but because the slasher movie
particularly the slasher movie that that
the book larry is parodying
is
it's not a uniquely american phenomenon
but a lot of those tropes are come from
a lot of like american slasher movies
and the fact that adam millard is
british uh i didn't actually realize
that when i first started reading it but
then like a couple of the turns of
phrase i'm just like oh he must be a
brit so it's just kind of like it's
strange because it's almost kind of like
he's trying to
make it seem like an american story but
then he can't help
like british isms coming out and it's
just kind of like so it was a little bit
weird at first because i was like oh he
must be british just because of one
particular you know phrase that he used
that that american would not use so it
was a little bit like what but then at
first but then after that it kind of
became sort of charming um and then i
started hearing it like in a british
accent which i don't know i could that
that kind of like um
made the experience better uh your
mileage may vary but yeah so keep that
keep that in mind even though it's a
very very american story and i think
it's even meant to be set in the united
states somewhere because he does refer
to jason and like new jersey and stuff
but it is a british writer and there's a
lot of british isms that people talk
like british people so just know that
going in so it might be a little weird i
don't know i found it weird at first but
i got used to it pretty quickly i will
say too this came out in 2014
and there are also two sequels because
of course there are uh because it's
based on slasher movie the larry two is
called the squeakquel um because well
because you know pigs and uh then the
third one i think is larry3 3d or
something like that uh so i'll
definitely be reading those two as well
because this movie this this book was
just uh just a delightful just a
delightful couple of hours and so like i
said it just a lot of the parts a lot of
the lines in it a lot of the
descriptions in it just made me like
laugh out loud
and if you have that kind of like sick
sense of humor then you will probably
really love this i really need to read
some of his other stuff too because i
didn't realize until i went on to his uh
amazon author page that he's written
like a [ __ ] shit-ton man he's written
like 26 novels it's like
13 novellas something like that in like
a few hundred short stories so you know
so
i've been kind of sleeping on this guy
you know not really knowing all that
much about him like i said i kept seeing
the book larry coming up in people's uh
you know recommendations even though it
came out like several years ago um so i
decided i would start there because it
was short and uh yeah and i liked it so
much that i'll definitely be reading
some uh other stuff of his in the future
and uh we'll see maybe we'll have to
maybe i'll do some more reviews of some
of his stuff because some of the you
know the
titles of them like looked really funny
and looked like something i'd be into so
you know like i said it's not for
everybody uh if you like
you know if you like kind of like you
know more cerebral ghost stories which i
do too uh no shame that's probably my
favorite but if you just want something
that's just like a good time
and you just want to like kill a couple
hours with like this just this crazy
slasher story like about
a slasher who's like an old man and he's
like trying to chop up teenagers and he
just can't do it like he used to um then
i think you will find uh you will find
this very very entertaining just as i
did
so yeah like i said it's if you have
kindle unlimited i would recommend
that's the way to do it um i'm sure you
can maybe get a paperback like it's kind
of used or something like that somewhere
but the only ones they have available on
amazon as far as i saw were like 800 so
i don't really know why that is but uh
you know uh like i said
kindle unlimited best way to go there
and as i said there are also two sequels
which i will probably eventually get to
as well and that will do it for tomes of
terror my little book review show i will
see you guys on the next one
bye